hallo mein name ist super lässig
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video feier am letzten wochenende in
berlin im schloss ich glaube die szenen
von dem schluss habe ich schon oft genug
gezeigt aber die sind doch eigentlich
recht cool und dort war ich ja von
freitag bis sonntag und am samstag hat
ja deutschland gespielt bei der em im
schönen italien geworden im
elfmeterschießen und ich bin ja fußball
fan und habe dann auch oftmals regel
emotionen bei einem spiel der grund
warum ich in berlin war einfach weil
mein netzwerk studio 71 dort so vorträge
gehalten hat sofort bildungsmäßig mit zu
dozenten die dann über motivation und
persönlichkeiten und youtube tipps
gegeben haben und so weiter und abends
gab es dann halt immer leckeres essen
und an dem samstagabend gab es dann nach
dem essen auch noch public viewing
deutschland gegen italien was wir dann
in seinem raum irgendwie zusammen mit 40
anderen leuten geguckt haben und die
sache war und das ist mir erst nach dem
public viewing aufgefallen dort stand
die ganze zeit ein typ mit einer kamera
und hat uns gefilmt wie wir da fußball
geguckt haben jedenfalls habe ich dann
am sonntag so den tag nach dem
deutschland gegen italien gewonnen hat
an die ganzen leute die es noch nicht
wissen deutschland im elfmeterschießen
gegen italien im viertelfinale gewonnen
und befindet sich jetzt im halbfinale wo
wir morgen gegen frankreich spielen
werden ich habe dann halt am tag danach
erfahren dass da einen typen der kamera
standen alle habe ich darauf
angesprochen hat sich angeblich fast
einen fernseher zerstört hatte beim
jubeln
habt ihr dann gebeten mir vielleicht die
dateien auf einer sd karte zu geben habe
die dann auch bekommen auf dem laptop
gezogen wir dann auf dem rückweg von
berlin angeschaut und auf benutzer luca
was war denn mit dir los ich zeige euch
jetzt mal sehen wie das ganze halt aus
als das spiel noch normal am laufen war
wohl noch nicht das elfmeterschießen
angefangen hat
das ist sensationell müller 14 hat er
seine vier mitarbeiter von schülern sind
viele youtube auf deutschland österreich
schweiz bootcamp teilnehmer leute die
bei diesem schlosser gearbeitet haben
und hat unter anderem auch mein account
manager und der hat sich über eine szene
dann auch ein bisschen aufgeregt und
zwar bastian schweinsteiger szene geld
bekommen anstatt dass er so als ganz
normaler mensch sagt okay er hat geld
bekommen kann jetzt nichts dran ändern
beschwere ich mich auch nicht wahr dass
hier seine reaktion ist ja gut gemacht
gut gemacht du bist ein typischer
fußballer ich saß halt ein bisschen
weiter hinten weil ich ja ich bin ein
bisschen zu spät gekommen zum public
viewing habe keinen guten platz mehr
bekommen und hat dann halt gedacht okay
wenn sich der elia so aufregt dann
schreib doch auch einfach mal um das
angeblich ein elfmeter war und das war
wirklich eine phase im spiel wo es nur
mittelfeldgeplänkel war oder ein streich
hat plötzlich rum
der google habe ich gesagt das ist
vielleicht gar kein elfer war sondern
nicht nur schreien wollte das spielen
dann halt irgendwie seinen lauf so
deutschland hat das 1 0 gemacht hätte
das 1 1 gemacht oder dann ging es
irgendwann in die verlängerung und ins
elfmeterschießen wo dann
was sollte man die reihenfolge beim
schießen jedenfalls hat der kameramann
der mir die ganzen system hat am
nächsten tag gegeben hat und dass auch
gefilmt hat dann nur die sachen gefallen
wo die leute dann irgendwie entweder
sagen ja leute getroffen neue hat
gehalten oder scheiße italien hat
getroffen
also bin ich euch jetzt mal ein paar
ausraster szenen von allen ein
und neben den szenen wo wir entweder
gesagt haben ja oder gab es auch eine
szene wo wir irgendwie alle erst gesagt
haben und danach und nähe weil wir uns
irgendwie alle erst mal guckt haben
da habe ich mir gedacht wie blöd sind
wir eigentlich
alle reisen ist die hände hoch dem pokal
und danach wieder her doch nicht drin
wenn ich scheiße
danach hat dann daniel waren so das
komplette spiel bisher erst ein bisschen
zusammengefasst ist es nicht mehr zurück
verschiesst einer nach dem anderen ok da
an den banken schon wieder eine tolle
zusammenfassung des spiels bisher
gemeint ist dass jeder nacheinander
verschießt überlegen oder nochmal kurz
wiedersehen meter schießen ausging aber
gut dass jeder verschießt ich finde
floyd hat auch ein sehr gutes statement
dann dafür gefunden
danke für deine sehr kompetente aussage
bezüglich des spiels sondern hat sich
irgendwann mein account manager ilja
vorne sah hingesetzt mit der
deutschlandflagge drum herum als wenn er
gerade ein unfall gehabt hätte und
irgendwie gewärmt werden müsste und dann
habe ich mir halt gedacht ja ich bin
auch in der totalen anspannungen und er
sitzt vorne komplett alleine setze ich
mich doch einfach mal zu ihm
man sagt sich da ein und damit ihr
gewartet bis der nächste schütze von
deutschland antritt
und dann hat dann getroffen und ich habe
mich auch ein wenig gefreut und jetzt
kommt nämlich auch schon die zweite
klasse szene von den ganzen aufnahmen
die ich euch heute zeigen werde und zwar
manuel neuer dann elfer gehalten in
italien geschossen hat sich halt hat ja
angefangen zu schießen das heißt die
tatsache dass war neuer die helfer
gehalten hat besagt weil sie das wenn
der nächste deutsche schütze trifft wir
weiterkommen aber das ist erst mal eine
reaktion auf die glanztat von manuel
neuer
jeder dachte in dem moment halt dass ich
den fernseher um box und hat mich
deswegen auch zurückgezogen
das ist mein motto dank an der stelle an
dich glaubst hätten sich alle leute im
raum gehasst und dann war ich halt so
richtig top es für diesen letzten schuss
von deutschland und der effektor halt
angelaufen hat den rhein gemacht und
dann bin ich halt ja seht einfach mal
selbst
ich bin aufgesprungen hat ein partner
auf den fernseher geschlagen der hatte
dann halben fackeln von tag dann habe
ich noch gläser und becher umgeschmissen
ich hab mich gefragt was ich allerdings
nicht verstanden hat ist dass danach
irgendwelche leute meinen ok-chef aus
hass mit rück aber die ganze zeit den
lichtschalter an- und aus deutschland
ist weiter erstmalig general ausdrucken
die ganze zeit war das macht so viel
spaß
marco leute da war halt auch irgendeine
andere youtuber rinnen und dachte halt
auch so nich ich freue mich jetzt nicht
ich filme einfach mal mitmachen self
grüße gehen raus und ich die szenen die
jetzt folgen waren halt dann einfach wie
ich mich dann noch so nachträglich
gefreut habe also mehr als moment hab
ich halt einfach mal alles um geboxt
richtig geschrieben so richtig dieses
mal kräftiger wir haben endlich mal
italien besiegt in der ko-runde da bin
ich dann wieder zu mir gekommen habe
mich gefreut und habe dann halt
irgendwelche leute umarmt ich auch gar
nicht richtig kannte
dann haben wir noch ein bisschen rum
geschrieben
und zu beginn wurde ich dann noch mal
gefilmt wie ich wirklich so die ganze
zeit vom fernseher stallung gedacht
alter wir haben gerade wirklich italien
besiegt so unnormal
es kam ich halt immer noch an die wm
2006 erinnern wo ich zehn jahre alt war
und geheult habe als wir gegen italien
rausgeflogen sind das war ein trick
schiebt so einen hass auf die
italienische nationalmannschaft
das war's von video meine damen und
herren ich wollte euch das heute
wirklich einfach mal zeigen weil ich
dieses sehen gefunden habe und bekommen
habe und das risiko das ist echt witzig
wenn euch diese story time sachen
gefallen wenn ich anhand von videos die
ich habe oder irgendwas einfach erzählen
dass auf jeden fall eine bewertung dar
und schreiten wenn die kommentare und
vonier das spiel geguckt hat und wie ihr
ausgerastet sein wahlkampf ausgesetzt
wie ich glaube das geht gar nicht ich
fahre auf jeden fall ultra krass und wir
sehen uns im nächsten video wieder rein